it took 64 days to get there
and joe biden tried to craft the opening
with a boost
we will by my 100th day in office have
administered
200 million shots in people's arms
that's right 200 million shots in
100 days i know it's ambitious
twice our original goal but no other
country in the world has even come
close not even close but on the border
an emerging problem with
far less progress the president called
crowded border facilities
unacceptable though denied the recent
surge in migrants was down to a
perception
he is a soft touch i'd like to think
it's because i'm a nice guy but it's not
it's because of what's happened
every year let me say one other thing on
this if you take a look
at the number of people are coming
the vast majority the overwhelming
majority of people
coming to the border crossing are being
sent back congratulations mr president
such as the curse of the washington
bubble he's already being asked if he'll
be back
in four years time have you decided
whether you are going to run for
re-election
in 2024 you haven't set up a re-election
campaign yet as your predecessor had by
this time
my predecessor need to need it to
my predecessor oh god i miss him
um no an answer is yes my plan is to run
for reelection that's my expectation
on foreign policy expectations he
painted a portrait of a complex
relationship
with china's leader xi jinping doesn't
have a democratic with a small d
bone in his body but he's a smart smart
guy
he's one of the guys like putin who
thinks that autocracy is the wave of the
future democracy can't function in an
ever com
an ever complex world but folks
i'm going thank you very very much i
appreciate it thank you
a quick exit for a man who wants to
limit his stage time
and deliver more than he promises